bonjour à tous les deux
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
pour débattre notamment de 2,7
réindustrialisation de la france qui
concerne évidemment tout le monde une
commission denquête chargé d'identifier
les facteurs qui ont conduit à la chute
de la part de l'industrie dans le pib et
d'en définir les moyens pour ré le
relocaliser l'industrie en france
notamment l'industrie du médicament
arnaud montebourg est auditionné tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée nationale je
commence donc par vous françois cocq
avez vous eu connaissance de ce rapport
est évidemment qu'elle quel bilan
faites-vous de cette
désindustrialisation de la france
qui les payent leur apport en 1 mais
comme tout le monde il semble que le
bilan soit assez évidente et j'espère
que la chaîne de responsabilités qui va
être établi par cette commission
d'enquêté perdant traversera port ira
jusqu'au bout
quand j'ai nié jusqu'au bout c'est que
les fils de la responsabilité
aujourd'hui se déploie jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'état
si nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui il
part de l'industrie qui ramené à
seulement 11 % dans le produit intérieur
brut de notre pays n'a où tous nos
voisins sont largement au dessus 23 %
pour l'allemagne 19% pour l'italie de
16% même pour nos amis espagnols nous
nous sommes totalement dessous pourquoi
parce que depuis des années l'industrie
française a été abandonnée vendu à la
découpe pensez seulement à la liste à la
litanie de ses fleurons français arcelor
et chine et alstom alcatel lafarge
techniques et tous les autres qui ont
été déposés depuis depuis des années
sous l'égide du pouvoir politique et
quand je dis sous l'égide du pouvoir
politique et j'ai commencé par là c'est
que le premier responsable aujourd'hui
siège à l'elysée c'est monsieur macron
la sphère alstom n'en finit plus d'avoir
des rebondissements et d'être un gramme
économique industrielle sociale dans
notre pays on a appris encore hier que
losing de reichshoffen va être
délocalisée
m reprise par les espagnols on a appris
qu en 2024 toute la branche énergie par
être déposée par les américains après
que monsieur macron les aborder quand il
est arrivé d'abord au ministère de
l'économie puis ensuite à la tête du
pays donc il faut mettre un coup d'arrêt
aujourd'hui à cela la fois mais je pense
que notre discussion nous permettre d'y
arriver henri industriels eux
industrialisant le pays et il ya de
nombreuses propositions d'arnaud
montebourg qui sont aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs de longue date sur la sur
l'attaqué sur cette question mais aussi
je le dis en allant chercher toutes
celles et tous ceux qui portent une
responsabilité dans cette affaire d'où
la proposition
mais françois cancon va en parler je
voudrais aussi que je remarque suppose
exprimons vallée dans le détail
évidemment des propositions d'arnaud
montebourg d'abord ce constat tout le
monde s'en est inquiétée de cette
désindustrialisation de la france quand
on a vu les images lors de la crise
sanitaire où on a vu ses avions importe
aider à porter des masques puisque la
france ne produisait pas voyez l'exposé
des motifs de la commission denquête et
je vous laisse réagir jean marc flipo
après
les images des ponts aériens depuis la
chine où la turquie ont mis en lumière
de manière crue la perte de souveraineté
de la france dans des domaines
industriels stratégiques
l'échec de sanofi à produire un vaccin
efficace contre le coc vie 19 juste à
poser succès d'autres industriels
européens n'ont fait qu'amplifier ce
sentiment au delà de ses seuls domaines
c'est l'ensemble du tissu industriel de
la france qui apparaît aujourd'hui
fragilisée jean-marc chipeau françois
cocq nous détaillait la vente des
fleurons français à l'étranger il aura
fallu cette crise sanitaire finalement
pour que le gouvernement se rendre
compte qu'il y avait urgence à rien de
se réaliser la france
faisait si le gouvernement serait pas
perçu plutôt nous c'est qu'il est
totalement sourd et aveugle la touffe
instinct c'est invraisemblable j'entends
aujourd'hui que sont des députés
socialistes vont faire une proposition
qui ont fait remis un rapport pour
savoir ce qui se passe n'est toi c'est
pas compliqué de savoir ce qui se passe
effectivement on du tout toute
l'industrie française à la découpe
depuis les années 90 rappelez-vous le
pdg d'alcatel qui voulait faire une
industrie son usine en france et ces
gens là sont effectivement gravitent
aujourd'hui dans l'entourage du
président de la république et mais on va
pas réinventer le tir n'a pas besoin de
commission on répond savoir ce qui se
passe moi j'étais je fais partie de la
génération mondialisation j'ai fait une
école de commerce internationale quand
j'étais jeune on ma dit aller en chine
parce que il faut qu' il faut
industrialiser la chine pour créer une
classe moyenne de manière à ce qu'on
puisse leur vendre nos produits mais moi
j'y suis allé en chine moi j'ai vu au
début des années 2000 le coût des
produits importés je suis tel 40 % d'une
année sur l'autre et parce que c'était
parce qu'on a pu avoir cette cette
baisse des coûts de production par
l'industrialisation progressive de la
chine un autre à nos dépends et par
l'introduction de l'euro qui a qui a
qu'à favoriser qui a favorisé sa au lieu
de créer une classe moyenne tension
l'axé mais on s'est complètement nous
démunis il ya eu un appel d'air un appel
aux gains absolument incroyable une
course aux profits incroyables qui était
renforcée par
la facilité du que gouvernement avait en
fait deux de lutter contre la pauvreté
en france simplement par les
importations puisque le coup le coût de
la vie diminue elle automatiquement avec
les importations chinoises donc tout le
monde est complice tout le monde est
responsable je me souviens aussi de
dominique de villepin au début des
années 2000 qui disait mais non mais
c'est pas grave les chinois vous allez
voir ils vont fabriquer des produits à
bas coûts et puis nous on va garder les
produits à haute valeur ajoutée parce
que en france en plus de ça à la tête de
l'état on ne s'est jamais départi d'une
condescendance absolument criminelle
voilà donc y'a aucun secret tout est sur
la table depuis depuis des décennies
effectivement leur aujourd'hui c'est
comme la cigale de la fontaine on jure
mais un peu tard qu'on ne l'y reprendra
plus sauf qu'il est effectivement bien
tard avec nicolas dupont aignan ça fait
maintenant deux campagnes électorales
qu'on a des propositions concrètes
industrialisés pays et il faut pas
attendre il faut le faire dès que
possible parce que l'indépendance de la
france et le l'avenir de la france en
europe et dans le monde qui passe
nécessairement par une radicalisation
l'un des premiers à défendre le made in
france c'était évidemment arnaud
montebourg ont parlé de ces propositions
ont valu on va les écouter justement
je veux créer un délit de trahison
économique car à chaque fois qu'il ya eu
des ventes à l'étranger il y a eu des
gros chèques qui sont arrivées sur les
comptes des dirigeants maintenant ça
suffit je considère que tous ces
vendeurs à la sauvette de la france en
pièces détachées doivent maintenant
répondre de leurs actes devant la
justice avec une responsabilité pénale
pour trahison économique une
responsabilité pénale pour trahison
économique françois cocq évidemment
c'est une des solutions mais il y en a
d'autres vous venez de diffuser un petit
reportage dans notre discussion sur ces
salariés de l'usiné sommes dans
l'aveyron une succursale de de renault
qui ont brûlé leur carte électorale de
la même manière que les gilets jaunes
ont répondu à l'urgence sociale à ce
besoin de dignité humaine il y a trois
ans en défilant sur les ronds points sur
les champs-elysées avec leur carte
électorale la main les gens nous disent
dans ce pays et ils ont raison il faut
que le pouvoir politique reprenne la
main sur le pouvoir économique il faut
que nous reprenions collectivement le
contrôle par le biais de la décision
publique par le biais de la souveraineté
populaire voilà ce qu'est l'enjeu
principal de l'élection de 2022 et pour
cela et pour cela il faut mettre les uns
et les autres devant leurs
responsabilités ils font il faut châtier
ceux qui ont failli ceux qui ont failli
devront donc répondre de leurs actes et
c'est pourquoi il ya effectivement cette
proposition dans notre beau dans le
mambourg de mettre en place ce délit de
trahison économique mais à côté de
ceux-ci il faut aussi se lancer dans la
reconstruction du pays se lancer dans la
reconstruction du pays ça veut dire
réinstaller sur notre territoire 500
industrie ça veut dire à peu près 7 par
département ne me dites pas que c'est
compliqué les japonais ont rapatrié par
exemple 1000 de 600 entreprises et cela
rapporte de l'argent cela a un coût 50
milliards à peu près mais cela rapporte
immédiatement parce qu'on rapatrie 70
milliards de chiffre d'affaires et dans
quels domaines dans tous les domaines à
la fois dans les domaines du quotidien
imaginez qu'on importe chaque année pour
plus de trois milliards d'euros d'
engrenages et andreu marche des choses
aussi simples est aussi essentiel mais
qu'à côté de ça on se dessaisit des
supraconducteurs je parlais d'alstom
tout à l'heure c'est alstom qui gérait
cette question des supraconducteurs
maintenant ils sont fabriqués aux états
unis on est le perte de savoir-faire
d'indépendance et de souveraineté sur
cette question là alors que sais-tu
producteurs sont nécessaires et
indispensables
par exemple pour la fusion nucléaire ou
pour la fabrication d'é dezeraud vienne
france
le politique qui vise au plein de
coureurs je vous le dis c'est une
politique vise au plein emploi parce que
tout n'a pas été essayé pour le plein
emploi c'est une révolution économique
et culturel c'est la révolution
économique et culturelle du made in
france le gouvernement a fait des appels
à projets pour relève relocaliser des
productions dans les secteurs critiques
au total france relance a investi un peu
plus de 800 millions d'euros dans 624
projet en un an jean marc flipo qu'en
pensez vous quels sont les secteurs
d'ailleurs donc il faut prioriser les
secteurs à réindustrialiser d'urgence
la question n'est pas vraiment là 800
millions d'euros enfin temps de vous
plaisantez cc c'est une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan en fait sérieux à un moment
donné d'un con qu'on fasse la chasse au
traître on sait très bien comment ça va
se terminer avec eux ce joli monde qui
dansent ensemble depuis des années ça va
pas aller bien loin sur ce qui s'est
passé à l' usine aveyronnaise et sur les
gilets jaunes je suis désolé si vous
voulez que les choses changent n'oubliez
pas votre carte d'électeur parce que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire manifesté
dès se réunir sur les ronds points
pourquoi pas mais si après s'est pas
traduit dans les faits dans les urnes ça
va ne savez jamais nulle part vous avez
des candidats dit souverainiste qui se
présentent à la ré élection
présidentielle si vous voulez
effectivement réindustrialiser le pays
y'a pas 40 solution il faut voter pour
eux il faut pas brûler sa carte
d'électeur savez einstein disait c'est
pas c'est pas ceux qui ont créé les
problèmes qui vont les résoudre vous
pouvez pas compter sur maintenant ce en
quoi nous croyons nous c'est plutôt à
l'incitation pas ce que ça veut dire que
c'est la loi de l'argent vit dans un
système économique
dont il faut tenir compte ya pas de
politique qui vaille en deux réalité il
faut donc que la production en france
fait plus avantageuse que la production
à l'étranger à plusieurs outils pour
cela tarif extérieur commun déjà de
l'europe qui permettent et permet d'y
remédier et puis surtout au niveau
national il faut faire des incitations
fiscales de ce que nous proposons c'est
que l'impôt sur les sociétés soit divisé
par deux pour tous les bénéfices
réinvestis en france voilà ça ce sont
des mesures d'incitation il faut que la
dépense publique aussi tirent cette ré
industrialisation en mettant en place
une forme de l équivalent à 2 du buy
american
de manière parce que il 75% des délais
des achats publics qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient réalisés en france ça c'est la
puissance publique doit tirer elle doit
inciter par la peau de manière à ce que
ça revient dernier point ce n'est plus
un pl on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement françois comme je suis
désolé on a largement on a largement
dépassé le temps imparti à ce débat je
suis je suis vraiment désolé de vous
couper la parole on en reparlera bien
évidemment pendant cette campagne
présidentielle merci en tout cas
françois cocq et et merci à vous jean
marc flipo d'avoir participé à ce débat